bon monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
compte tenue de l'Ance du secteur du
logement dans les débats autour du
projet de loi de finances nous avons
souhaité entendre Monsieur Patrice
vergrit ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires chargé du
logement monsieur le ministre d'ailleurs
vous serez le seul ministre audité c'est
dire l'importance que nous attachons à
cette rencontre c'est la première fois
euh que vous venez devant notre
commission et bien sûr je vous souhaite
tout particulièrement la
bienvenue pe vous dire également que je
suis heureux évidemment à titre
personnel de vous retrouver euh après
des des étapes que nous avons connu
ensemble direction d'agence d'urbanisme
du local maire président d'agence
d'urbanisme euh et président de la
fédération nationale de l'athno l'agence
d'urbanisme votre tâche nous le savons
n'est pas facile alors que le secteur de
la construction neuve fait face à la
chute des ventes et que la hausse des
taux oblige les candidats au logement à
différer leurs projets le logement
social n'est guerre en meilleure forme
les délais d'attente sont toujours
pointés du doigt tandis que le nombre de
logement neuf s'est sensiblement réduit
au cours des dernières années le projet
de loi de finance contient quelques
mesures vous nous expliquerez
certainement ce que vous en entendez
attendez pardon car certaines ont été
ajoutées dernièrement dans le texte sur
lequel le gouvernement a engagé sa
responsabilité donc nous manquons
forcément quelques peu d'éléments pour
en apprécier l'impact autant dire que
nous vous écouterons avec la plus grande
attention et nous ne serons d'ailleurs
pas les seuls puisque je vous rappelle
que cette audition est retransmise sur
le site internet du Sénat et je suis à
peu près certain qu'elle va être très
suivie monsieur le ministre je vous
donne tout de suite la parole pour une
introduction du
sujet merci monsieur le Président
bonjour à à toutes et à tous merci aussi
pour votre invitation je suis ravi de
pouvoir être le seul que vous puissiez
auditionner tant effectivement le le
sujet du logement est un est un enjeu
important me semble-t-il aujourd'hui je
ne vais pas vous faire l'injure de
rappeler les les quatre grands objectifs
finalement de de la politique du
logement dans notre pays un objectif à
caractère économique puisque le logement
c'est aussi de l'emploi notamment de
l'emploi dans le bâtiment mais aussi
finalement la politique du logement se
donne pour objectif le logement
abordable la capacité pour tout à chacun
finalement d'accéder au au logement dont
dont il rêve et dont il a besoin un
objectif environnemental veiller à ce
que chacun des logements puisse
contribuer à la transition énergétique
un objectif social qui se traduit par
les enjeux d'hébergement d'urgence mais
aussi la capacité d'accorder un logement
digne et descant à à chacun d'entre nous
et enfin un objectif territorial
c'estàdire cette capacité donné à la
politique du logement de s'adapter à la
réalité des territoires ces quatre
grands objectifs qui fond de ce qui est
une politique dur
du logement en France économique
environnemental social et territorial
sont les objectifs naturels de la
politique du logement sauf que ces
grands objectifs sont touchés vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président
aujourd'hui par une crise une crise
multifactorielle si je m'exprime de
manière un peu technique une crise
d'abord économique qu'on sentait poindre
depuis de nombreuses années avec la
croissance des prix immobiliers la la
spécialisation de la construction de
logement en France vers la maison zone
détendue la maison individuelle éloignée
de la ville en zone détendue et les
dispositifs d' fiscalinvestissement
locatif dans les dans les grandes villes
et qui est venu j'ai envie de dire
couper une dynamique qui a été coupé par
la croissance forte des taux d'intérêt
des taux d'intérêts qui sont passés de
1,2 % à 4,2 % en même temps
l'augmentation du coût des
matériaux finalement tout se passe comme
si notre pays avait des prix fonciers
adaptés à des taux d'intérêt à 1 % au
moment où ils sont à 4,2 % et donc
évidemment cette crise de la production
est là - 38 % de crédit immobiliers
accordés - 16 % de mise en chantier - 28
% des logements autorisés on a donc bien
une première crise qui est d'une crise
de la production du logement cette crise
n'est pas la seule crise que connaît le
logement aujourd'hui également une crise
environnementale avec des besoins
d'accélération des rénovations
énergétiques des logements une crise
sociale avec la croissance de
l'hébergement d'urgence qui est passé de
93000 places d'hébergement d'urgence à
203000 places aujourd'hui à à cela
s'ajoute une crise démographique avec le
vieillissement de la population et un
besoin d'adaptation fort donc une crise
multifactorielle sur l'ensemble des
dimensions de de la politique
d'urgence finalement face à cette crise
particulièrement aigue et et
multifacteur
l'idée que le modèle ancien
puisse faire repartir aujourd'hui le
logement bah but sur la la réalité et
notamment sur l'articulation entre
production et réponse aux transitions
écologique et à la nécité d'adapter les
logements au vieillissement et donc ce
sont des nouvelles réponses qui sont
nécessaires pour
pouvoir soutenir aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des des besoins et dépasser les diff
différentes crises de la politique du
logement l'idée est finalement de
trouver une politique du logement plus
adaptée à ce que doit être la ville du
21e siècle donc tous les outils de la
politique du logement ont besoin d'être
profondément
repensé la priorité bien entendu et
l'urgence est d'abord une urgence
économique aujourd'hui avec une urgence
liée à la crise de de la production
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans ce
projet de loi finance vousetrouver un
certain nombre de premières mesures à
caractère
financier et fiscal
d'abord sur le pour l'accession à la
propriété un préatoau zéro qui est
recentré mais qui est boosté à la fois
dans les qutités à la fois dans les
plafonds à la fois dans les publics
éligibles l'idée finalement c'est de
pouvoir maintenir le même nombre de pré
àau zé avec une géographie plus
recentrée à ce à ce renforcement du
préateau zéro dans les zones les plus
tendues c'est ajouté
une volonté d'adapter les zonages vous
avez vu que nous avions fait un premier
décret qui a permis à d'autres
territoires de rentrer en zone tendue
donc affiner les zonages essayer de
faire que le prê à zé soit renforcé dans
les zones où il y en a le plus besoin
pour privilégier un pré à zéro dans
l'ancien sur la rénovation dans les
secteurs où la vacance est la plus
élevée et qui nécessite davantage du
recyclage urbain sur la question
accession à la propriété nous
travaillons aussi avec Bruno Le Maire
sur la question de l'accès au crédit
immobilier tout à l'heure je l'aiévoqué
moin 38 % de crédit
immobilier le but du jeu est d'essayer
de convaincre euh en tout cas d'échanger
avec le gouverneur de la Banque de
France sur la question des sous-critères
mais j'aurai l'occasion d'y d'y revenir
35 % de
ratio mensualité sur revenus 25 % de
durée de prêt c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas ça qui est évoqué aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement mais plutôt les 20 % de
marges qui sont données aux banques
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas pleinement
utilisé puisque seulement 13 % de ces
marges sont utilisé par les banques car
il y a des sous-critères par exemple 70
% de Primot excédent dans les 20 % de
marges et c'est sur ces sous-critères
aujourd'hui que nous discutons avec le
gouverneur de la Banque de France nous
soutenons également le bail réel
solidaire nous soutenons également la
vente HLM Vous avez vu les annonces que
nous avons fait au au au Congrès HLM
pour essayer de doper aussi
l'avantage ça c'est sur l'accession à la
propriété sur deuxè élément que nous
souhaitons renforcer c'est le logement
locatif intermédiaire avec un zonage là
aussi qui a été adapté pour permettre à
plus de territoires de pouvoir en
bénéficier et dans ce projet de loi de
finance vous avez une extension du
bénéfice du logement locatif
intermédiaire à toutes les catégories de
fonds d'investissement qui peut
permettre finalement au particulier de
revenir dans le financement du logement
locatif intermédiaire via ces fonds
d'investissement sur le logement locatif
social je revenais tout à l'heure sur
l'accord qui a été trouvé avec le
mouvement
HLM de manière à pouvoir tenir à la fois
un objectif ambitieux de rénovation
énergétique du parc social vous savez
que 9,5 % du parc social est encore
aujourd'hui passoir thermique ce qui est
nettement mieux que le parc Pr hein
puisquon est moitié moindre néanmoins il
y a un rythme à tenir et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement a fait
l'annonce à Nant d'un d'un fond de 1,2
milliards sur 3 ans pour accompagner à
la rénovation
énergétique des logements sociaux et
accompagné d'un certain nombre de prêts
de la Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation
pour accélérer la production des prêts
qui euh équivalent à à peu près 650
millions d'économie de charg d'intérêt
pour les bailleurs ça a été également le
maintien du taux du livréa à à 3 %
encore pendant un an et demi et c'est
aussi le suivi de l'application de la
loi SRU donc vous savez que nous sommes
actuellement au moment du bilan triénal
et nous engageons des contrats de mixité
sociale avec les communes carencées de
manière à pouvoir développer la
production de logements sociaux dans les
communes qui en ont besoin un plan
logement étudiant est également en
préparation en essayant de travailler
sur les fonciers universitaires
disponibles la transformation de bureaux
en résidence étudiante puisque vous
savez que la transformation de bureaux
en logements familiaux est plus
difficile techniquement mais plus facile
sur des transformations en résidence
étudiante donc tout som en train de
travailler là-dessus mais j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir j'essaie de
balayer l'ensemble de la politique du
lagement vous avez également dans ce
projet de loi de finance des
dispositions sur le foncier notamment le
renforcement d'abattement de de
plus-value de session foncière euh euh
un certain nombre de de de dispositifs
existent dans ce projet de loi de de
finan sur les questions foncières
évidemment je rappelle aussi l'existence
du fond vert qui permet aussi
d'accompagner fortement le recyclage
urbain le travail que nous avons fait
avec Olivier Grégoire et Christophe
Béchu sur la transformation des entrées
de ville notamment des zones
commerciales en entrée de ville où des
fonciers sont disponibles et nous sommes
aujourd'hui en train de discuter avec
les foncières commerciales pour la
transformation de ces fonciers et y
ajouter évidemment des logements si je
continue dans dans les aides qui sont
aujourd'hui des réponses à la crise de
la production vous avez évidemment ce
plan de soutien de 47000 logement plan
de rachat en fait de logement à des
promoteurs 30000 de la part d'Action
Logement 17000 de la part de CDC habitat
chacun des deux étant aujourd'hui aux
alentours de 11000 12000 achat donc il
reste encore des possibilités de rachat
par ces deux entités une mission
parlementaire qui vient d'être lancée
sur la réforme de la fiscalité locative
je préfère d'ailleurs aborder dire
réforme de la fiscalité locative plutôt
que statut du bailleur privé qui est
peut-être un petit peu moins net mais
l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir évaluer la
question de la justice fiscale face à
l'investissement locatif mais aussi
quelque part l'incitation pour les
particuliers à s'engager dans
l'investissement locatif ce sera la
double mission euh le double travail
pardon de cette mission parlementaire de
travailler finalement à la fois sur les
meblet touristique mais aussi finalement
sur la promotion de l'investissement
locatif le plan gouvernemental de lutte
contre la vacance qui se poursuit je
pense que vous connaissez la possibilité
pour les communes d'avoir euh de pouvoir
identifier les propriétaires qui sont
concernés par des logements vacants et
de pouvoir évidemment avoir directement
accès à eux la prime de sortie de la
vacance de l'ANA la taxe sur les
logements vacants le Pr le pré àau zéro
dans l'ancien sur rénovation donc tout
ce travail pour lutter contre la vacance
se poursuit en matière de rénovation
énergétique vous avez dans ce projet de
loi de finances une dotation de Lana qui
est calibrée à 5 milliards d'euros donc
400 millions d'euros pour le logement
locatif social ce que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure quand je parlais du fond de 1,2
milliards d'euros sur 3 ans l'objectif
c'est d'atteindre 200000 rénovations
d'ampleur donc 80000 en copropriété avec
davantage d'accompagnement puisque le
but de ma prime renove c'est de pouvoir
réussir la transition entre du
financement de de changement de vecteur
énergétique à de la rénovation globale
et donc plus d'accompagnement des des
particuliers et des propriétaires pourou
voir atteindre cet objectif donc vous
avez dans ce projet de loi de finance
des mesures qui visent à renforcer
l'aide de l'État qui peut aller jusqu'à
90 % du fin de montant des travaux pour
les ménages très modestes donc dans ce
cadre-là la prolongation de l'écho PTZ
et la simplification du vote en
copropriété la création de ma prime
adapte qui a vocation à rassembler 1,5
milliards d'euros d'ici la fin du
quinquina déjà 250 millions engagés en
2024 pour permettre aux personnes
d'adapter leur log notamment au
contraintes du vieillissement mais aussi
du handicap évidemment pour préparer à
cette révolution démographique que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure qui était le
vieillissement de la population sur
l'hébergement d'urgence vous avez
également dans ce projet de loi de
finance le maintien d'un haut niveau de
nombre de plac d'hébergement d'urgence à
203000 places qui est le record
historique et même des éléments
complémentaires pour les femmes victimes
de violence qui fait qu'on pourra
augmenter même encore ce ce chiffre de
203000 places voilà un petit peu ce que
ce que vous retrouverez autour ou dans
ce projet de de loi de finan cela c'est
une étape dans la transformation de la
politique du logement que nous sommes
dans laquelle nous sommes engagés vous
avez également pu voir
que nous avions confié à Mathieu anotin
et Michel Ludz un rapport sur les
copropriétés dégradées et l'habitat
indine celui-ci a été rendu il a
vocation d'ici à la fin de l'année de
donner lieu à des mesures à caractère
réglementaire et financier de la part du
gouvernement donc d'ici la fin de
l'année et les mesures à caractère
législatif on vocation à être dans un
projet de loi qui doit arriver sur vos
table au premier trimestre 2024 donc un
projet de loi sur l'habitat indigne et
les copropriétés dégradées avec de
nouvelles mesures législatives et enfin
le président de la République l'a
annoncé l'arrivée aussi sur votable
d'une grande loi logement au printemps
en 2024 avec plusieurs objets le premier
objet la décentralisation de la
politique du logement donc effectivement
qui fait quoi dans la politique du
lâement et comment on donne surtout la
possibilité aux acteurs de terrain
d'avoir plus de capacité d'agir
aujourd'hui en matière de politique du
logement un sans doute aussi des
questions autour de l'avenir du logement
social Vous avez vu que la première
ministre a annoncé au comité
interministériel des villes la volonté
de ne plus se voir attribuer par est
préfet des ménages d'Allot en très
grande précarité dans les quartiers en
politique de la ville cela vient de de
la l'attachement que nous avons au
modèle généraliste du logement social et
place la mixité aussi sociale aussi
comme un enjeu à côté du droit au
logement cette question de l'avenir du
logement social notamment la nécessité
d'arbitrer entre un renforcement du
modèle généraliste avec une vocation de
mixité sociale ou un modèle résiduel à
qui concentrerait les plus démunis et
quelques quelque chose qui pourra aussi
être débattu dans le cadre de la loi
logement avec pour perspective pourquoi
pas derrière d'adapter les modalités des
attributions de logements sociaux en
fonction effectivement des orientations
choisies sur le logement social c'est
une loi qui peut aborder les rapports
locatifs c'est une loi qui peut aborder
un certain nombre de sujets j'ai envie
de dire je la résumerai en en en la
phrase suivante il s'agit finalement
d'adapter la politique du logement à ce
que doit être aujourd'hui le modèle de
développement territorial du 21e siècle
nous avons finalement des outils de la
politique du logement qui correspondent
à une autre époque sans doute du modèle
de développement territorial aujourd'hui
le covid est parci par là la nécessité
de s'adapter à la transition écologique
est passé par là le lien emploi logement
aussi qui est de plus en plus affiché
dans les territoires et passer par là et
nécessite finalement que ce modèle du
développement territorial soit repensé
et qui dit nouveau modèles de
développement territorial 10 nouveaux
outils de la politique du logement ce
sont ces nouveaux outils qui qui doivent
pouvoir se traduire dans cette grande
loi logement finalement comment on
souhaite que la politique du logement
demain contribue au développement
territorial souhaité voilà monsieur le
Président ce que je souhaitais évoquer
en introduction pour pour à la fois
évoquer des éléments qui sont dans le
projet de loi finance 2024 mais aussi
aller un peu au-delà pour essayer
d'exprimer tout ça se situe dans une
dans un cadre plus large de réforme de
la politique duug merci monsieur le
ministre je vais tout de suite donner la
parole au rapporteur
général merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai l'impression à vous avoir
écouté
que la chef du gouvernement a bien fait
de changer de ministre du
Logement puisque là on a un tableau à la
fois où on ant un grand volontarisme et
des perspectives que je qualifierais
presque d'un peu idylique en tous les
cas dans le ton qui est le vôtre qui je
dirais malheureusement se fracasse un
peu
sur sur la réalité actuel puisque moi
j'ai j'ai sorti un petit graphique qui
me donne le nombre de logements neuf
cumulés sur 12 mois entre les logements
autorisés autorisés et les log
commencé si on regarde de
sur le schéma sur une dizaine
d'années on retombe aux plus mauvaises
périodes donc comme dirait l'autre j'ai
eu l'occasion plusieurs fois
d'interpeller le ministre de l'Économie
et finances en lui disant maintenant au
travail je pense qu'il y a du boulot il
faut de la sueur de chef mais ça suffit
pas y compris me semble-t-il dans ce que
ce qui vient d'être mercredi sur la
manière de
travailler les publics dans les les zone
urbaine alors qu'on appelle quartier
sensible politique de la ville
renouvellement urbain j'en pas c'est des
meilleurs beaucoup de il y a il y a dans
la fin de votre propos je crois qu'il y
a il y a un sujet me semble-t-il les les
précédents enfin ce que le balayage
général met les points forts points fa
mais il y a je crois qu'il y a un
phénomène
nouveau en tous les cas moi je l'entends
et je sur le terrain c'est effectivement
le lien emploi
logement je dis nouveau parce que il
fait écho
euh à ce que l'on constate également
c'est-à-dire une pénurie
d'emploi et concomitamment le fait que
nos concitoyens de tous âges et je
dirais presque de toutes conditions
sont assez enclins à changer plus
facilement
qu'hier de
d'emploi parfois même sous forme de
d'intérim ou de contrat à durée
déterminée c'estàd et
donc il y a il y a il y a le sujet de la
mobilité et de la proximité entre
souvent je dis bien souvent c'est pas
toujours l'emploi et comment dirais-je
le logement moi je je vais me contenter
de de de vous poser trois questions on
pourrait comme on est nombreux vous
allez voir les les les les les questions
ne vont pas manquer parce que quand même
le logement me semble-t-il est
aujourd'hui
englué dans une crise qui à mon avis est
assez structurel donc il faudra du temps
pour en sortir et il faut qu'on prenne
garde les uns et les autres dans nos
responsabilités respective à ne pas
promettre un printemps dès demain parce
que là aussi je pense que on créerait
plus on se créerait plus de
difficultés le on a une mission de de de
l'IGF qui avait il y a un peu plus d'un
an remis au gouvernement un rapport qui
recommandait de de supprimer l'avantage
fiscal des meublés touristiques classés
donc le gouvernement par voie
d'amendement cette année a proposé une
mesure dans ce sens j'aurais simplement
besoin de savoir est-ce que enfin est-ce
qu'on peut avoir connaissance des des
des principales conclusions du rendement
qui en est attendu parce que il va
falloir regarder quel est le coût
d'ailleurs pour les propriétaires
concernés qui vont avoir un impôt
supplémentaire à quitté lequel n'a pas
été comment dirais-je anticipé il y a la
classification des zones A B et C et
comment tout
cela va se traduire notamment dans les
stations de haute
montagne puisque il y avait un
attachement au régime fiscal actuel des
meublés touristiques
classés un deuxième sujet sur le préatau
zéro j'ai bien noté il est recentré et
boosté il il va servir également pour la
rénovation et notamment pour du
recyclage urbain donc plusieurs
questions un sur quel dans quel
territoire puisque si c'est au sens
latin du terme urbain ça va ça je
considère que tous les territoires
peuvent être éligibles je crains que ça
ne soit pas tout à fait le cas donc
est-ce que vous avez d'ors et
déjà je dirais une carte nous permettant
de de mieux apprécier les choses sachant
que la Fédération Française bancaire a
estimé qu'en ouvrant le
dispositif ça ne créait à priori que que
que de l'ordre de d'une quinzaine de
milliers de nouveaux bénéficiaires
est-ce que vous confirmez
mais voilà qui qui rentre qui sort dans
dans le dans le dispositif et puis le
troisème sujet c'est sur le le le le le
financement du logement social où j'ai
l'impression que le le finalement le le
cadre n'est pas parfaitement clair
puisque les aides le financement ne ne
proviendrait bientôt désormais que du
déblocage des crédit du du FNAP et donc
ma question c'est alors je vois pour
2024 mais en 2025 si si les
contributions des bailleurs sociaux
venaient à se réduire ce qui est a
priori prévu et
programmé et par exemple qu'action
logement ne viendrait à plus
financer quels seront queles seraient
les modalités de
financement que vous souhaitez ou en
tout les cas que vous
prévoyez merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je vous propose monsieur le
ministre de répondre au rapporteur
général gér dans un premier temps si
vous voulez bien j'y joindrai juste un
bout de question
euh dans le cette question du logement
que je connais aussi depuis quelques
années euh comme beaucoup
ici la difficulté c'est finalement de
passer du discours d'orientation
politique euh vous avez démarré par ce
point c'était important de le faire euh
et ensuite on passe généralement à une
succession de
mesure voire quelquefois de micro mesur
ou de mini mesur par rapport aux
objectifs qui sont annoncés et le lien
entre les deux est un peu compliqué à
faire autrement dit est-ce qu'il est
d'après vous dans un
délai raisonnable possible de construire
une espèce de de
progression de vision des choses non pas
par mesure mais par résultat de ces
mesures c'est-à-dire un peu si les
mesures marchaient toutes qu'est-ce
qu'ell produit produise qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en espérer et dans quel délai de
manière à avoir un
peu une une un objectif qui ne soit pas
uniquement un objectif de dépense
budgétaire mais plutôt un objectif de
réalisation d'objectifs vous voyez ce
que je veux dire voilà je vous laisse
répondre alors comme l'a dit le
rapporteur général ne vous étonnez pas
c'est à peu près tout le monde ici va
prendre la parole sur le sujet ça a bien
démarré rien qu'avec la liste d'attente
si je peux dire je suis déjà au 2 tiers
donc vous voyez ça m'étonnerait pas que
tout le monde prenne la parole donc je
je vous inviterai donc en même temps à
une certaine concision comme d'ailleurs
à mes collègues pour ce qui est de poser
les questions merci monsieur le
Président c'est pas mon fort la
constition un sujet passionnant
euh alors d'abord monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement je partage totalement
votre votre analyse d'un élément qui a
évolué effectivement depuis une
vingtaine d'année donc depuis
l'évolution du cadre de la politique
duugement la politique duement s'est
fondée sur un cadre qui aujourd'hui est
à remettre en à plat complètement et
dans cette remise à plat le lien emploi
logement a pris beaucoup d'importance
ces questions de mobilité cette question
de proximité aussi de l'emploi et je
pense que quand on parlait de la grande
loi logement ça suppose effectivement de
repenser la politique du logement avec
ces nouveaux éléments le lien emploi
logement est pas le seul élément je
parlais tout à l'heure du covid qui a
changé profondément la façon dont on
aborde la question du logement
aujourd'hui je pense à la transition
écologique je pense au vieillissement de
la population tout ça doit nous
permettre de reposer finalement le cadre
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on veut pour la
politique du logement et du coup de tout
ça doit décliner des outils y compris
par exemple tout à l'heure la question
de l'attribution des logements sociaux
est-ce que demain la question du lien
emploi logement doit aussi rentrer dans
la logique des attributions de logements
sociaux est-ce que demain par exemple on
peut se voir attribuer un logement
social parce que ce serait plus proche
de son emploi c'est des questions qui
pourront être
posées dans le cette cadre dans le cadre
de cette grande loi logement
euh sur la question du régime du régime
de meubl
touristique classé
effectivement passé de 71 à 50 % dans ce
projet de de loi de finances c'est un
c'est un sujet qui a fait beaucoup de
débat qui a suscité beaucoup de
polémique moi-même je me suis exprimé à
mon donné du du débat dans dans l'un des
des journaux
nationaux la la première ministre a
souhaitait avoir une position de sagesse
sur ce point finalement en disant on a
besoin avant de de prendre une position
un peu définitive sur la fiscalité de
l'investiss la fiscalité locative avoir
une mission parlementaire qui entre
guillemets pose le stylo regarde tous
les effets de bord possibles et vous en
avez évoqué vous avez évoqué les
stations de montagne donc une analyse
plus en profondeur des effets de bord
potentiels pour essayer effectivement
d'aborder l'ensemble de la fiscalité
locative en intégrant finalement tout ce
qu'on souhaite mettre dedans à la fois
des notions de justice fiscale qu'est-ce
qui justifie aujourd'hui finalement
d'avoir un abattement plus important
pour du meublé par rapport au non meublé
par exemple qui est une question qu'on
pourrait se poser demain là c'est une
différence de 5030 qui est maintenu dans
le projet de loi de finance aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui justifie effectivement le
que le classé tourisme vaille 71 % et
puis des mesures aussi d'incitation
qu'est-ce qui peut permettre demain à
nos concitoyens d'investir davantage
dans le locatif donc c'est une mesure
j'ai envie de dire presque d'attente qui
a été proposé là en 71 pour 50 qui n'a
pas vocation effectivement à être
peut-être la dernière évolution de cette
fiscalité locative mais si j'ai envie de
dire un premier pas qui a été proposé
par le ministre de l'économie et des
finances vers sans doute c'est ce que la
mission parlementaire doit nous donner
des éléments peut-être plus avancé de
réforme de la fiscalité locative donc
voilà le sens du projet de loi de
finance une sorte de premier pas vers
quelque chose qui pourrait être plus
abouti au cours de l'année 2024 le prê à
taux zéro la diff érence en fait vous
avez vu deux chiffres effectivement et
vous l'avez rappelé c'est la Fédération
Française du du bâtiment qui a rappelé
ce chiffre de 15000 nouveaux
bénéficiaires versus 6 millions de
ménages éligible oui la Fédération
bancaire a dû reprendre aussi à mon avis
la Fédération française du bâtiment qui
l'a dit aussi ben c'est tout simplement
le nombre en fait c'est le nombre de
d'un côté de public éligible on aura
bien 6 millions de Français de plus
éligible versus le nombre de prêts qu'on
peut en attendre et on peut sans doute à
partir de 6 million de Français
éligibles avoir probablement 15000 prè
àau zé de plus et donc du coup garder ce
ce montant de 40000 à 45000 prêt à tau 0
en 2024 que nous avons en 2023 donc
entre le public éligible et le nombre de
prêts qu'on peut en attendre voilà
simplement la différence entre 6
millions et 15000 mais mais les deux
chiffres se valent en fait ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'avevec ce renforcement
et cette ce recentrage du prê àau zéro
on attend le même nombre de prê àau zéro
en 2024 qu'en 2023 c'est-à-dire que le
renforcement du préato Zéro euh j'ai
envie dire rille élimine la dimension du
recentrage garde quelque chose d'assez
booster sur la question du logement
locatif social et le devenir du du fnaap
effectivement aujourd'hui en 2024 nous
avons une contribution d'Action Logement
là aussi de la même manière je pense que
le le débat que nous aurons dans le
cadre de la grande loi logement et
notamment le débat que nous aurons plus
particulièrement sur le thème de la
décentralisation de la politique du
logement doit permettre de répondre
aussi à cette question finalement est-ce
que demain c'est aux futurs aoh parce
que ce sont les aoh qui seront
évidemment la
base de de de la politique du logement
de manière décentralisée est-ce que
demain ce sont les aach qui doivent
effectivement assurer l'aide à la pierre
avec quelles ressources ça sera
forcément l'une des questions qui va
émerger de cette grande loi logement et
notamment dans son chapitre
décentralisation donc difficile de
répondre à votre question tant qu'on n
pas eu ce débat notamment avec les
associations d'élus pour savoir
effectivement demain qui portera l'aide
l'aide à la pierre donc j'ai envie de
dire c'est pour moi il est un peu
prématuré de répondre avant le débat sur
la décentralisation de la politique du
logement dévolution de de l'aide à la
pierre et enfin monsieur le Président
par rapport à votre question je partage
totalement finalement très rapidement
d'ailleurs je le disais souvent aux
médias très rapidement finalement une
fois qu'on a posé une première question
politique sur la politique du logement
céd est-ce que tout le monde a un toit
est-ce que voilà on arrive très vite au
tuyau et au tuyau assez incompréhensible
d'ailleurs et on est très vite dans le
verbiage et dans les acronymes et et
finalement on voit pas toujours le lien
entre une vision ou un résultat et des
tuyaux et et et des engagements de de
dépenses c'est quelque chose qu'on
souhaite faire évoluer et fonctionner
effectivement beaucoup plus par objectif
de résultat les attributions de
logements sociaux illustrent bien votre
propos parce que finalement on a inventé
des dispositifs législatifs
réglementaires assez exceptionnels sur
les commissions attribution de logement
on devrait donc avoir des résultats
exceptionnels vu le nombre de critères
qui sont donnés aux attributions de
logements sociaux et bien pourtant
malgré tout ça dans les carartier de la
politique de la ville on continue à
avoir la concentration de la misère donc
comme quoi effectivement en étant dans
une logique purement procédurale en
écrivant finalement que sur les moyens
de la politique du logement et en
nincrivant pas sur ces objectifs on
finit par ne plus finalement atteindre
ces objectifs tant on complexifie
quelque chose qui c'est la logique
procédurale n'est pas une bonne façon
d'atteindre le rés at donc je partage
totalement votre vision de la politique
du logement à force de parler procédures
on en a fini par oublier quel était
l'objectif de toutes ces procédures et
je pense que revenir à des objectifs de
résultat et là je vous ai donné un bon
exemple me semblerait effectivement
particulièrement utile donc je partage
totalement votre point de vue sur les
outils de la politique
d'urg merci monsieur le ministre en
matière de résultat moi voyez j'ai j'ai
réussi c'est-à-dire qu'on a bien
quasiment la totalité des élus qui sont
inscrits euh ce qui va euh nous nous
nous permettre de demander à chacun de
s'en tenir à 90 secondes une minute 30
pour une intervention ce qui amène à une
synthèse encore plus
importante que d'habitude et nous allons
commencer pour nous donner le là par
Bruno
[Musique]
Belin merci président monsieur le
ministre ravi de vous vous revoir dans
cette maison la dernière fois je vous
avais interrogé c'était quand vous avez
candidaté pour présider l'agence euh de
financement des infrastructures de
transport et je vous ais demandé si vous
resterez plus longtemps que votre
prédécesseur Jean Castex vous ne l'avez
dépassé que de quelques semaines en tout
cas ravi de vous voir et comme le dit le
rapporteur général moi je doute pas de
votre bonne volonté en tout cas vous
l'exprimez mais vous avez dans cette
liste de multifactoriel de la crise ce
loger va devenir de plus en plus
difficile vous avez oubli quelques
points que je me permets de vous
rappeler parce que nous y sommes
forcément très sensibles ici la question
du zan du Zéro artificial sur Net vous
avez pas du tout parlé ce qui va faire
qu'augmenter le coût du logement parce
que la déconstruction pour faire de la
construction on voit bien déjà et
notamment les bailleurs sociaux sont le
fond marqué la question de sortir tous
les logements passoir du parc locatif va
avoir une incidence terrible notamment
dans le milieu urbain paupérisé et puis
vous n'avez pas du tout évoquer et nous
vivons nous sur le terrain les
territoires les question de l'arrivée
des pui qui va y avoir une disproportion
entre ce qui sera possible de faire en
milieu rural ou ce qui sera nécessaire à
faire en milieu urbain en tout cas le
milieu rural va se trouver évidemment
très frustré puisque pratiquement plus
aucun projet ne va pouvoir sortir sur
des dizaines de milliers de de
collectivité alors ce c'est le bon vieux
principe he ce qui est rare va devenir
cher donc complexité à à se loger moi je
trouve que complexité rime avec
difficulté le prê à tau zéro enfin
sincèrement c'est pas avec ça que vous
faites de l'accession à la propriété
j'entends votre ambition on va arriver
peut-être à 15000 de plus sur 6 millions
c'està dire 0,25
% du potentiel donc on est quand même
sur une ambition qui me semble un peu
légère il y a des choses que vous n'avez
pas évoqué qu'on ressent et qu'on entend
sur les territoires Lana c'est très
difficile Lana c'est ça vient quand quoi
les là si vous pouvez faire accélérer
donner des instructions à vos services
ça serait évidemment assez
extraordinaire zone tendue tout le
territoire national va être tendu parce
que zan parce que P lui parce que coût
du logement le logement social le
constat c'est divisé par 4 et donc ma
question est simple est-ce que après le
futur feu dispositif Pinel il y
aura-t-il un dispositif ver Grit ou
enfin on avir une politique du logement
ambitieuse et efficace et qui évitera
les mini mesures merci Bruno Hervé Mor
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je suis également très heureux
de vous retrouver parce que moi je vous
ai auditionné dans cette salle dans dans
le cadre de vos fonctions précédentes
j'aurais bien sûr comme tous mes
collègues beaucoup de questions à poser
je vais me limiter une question que j'ai
déjà posé lors d'une question orale le 6
juin dernier comme je n'ai pas eu de
réponse je l'ai confirmé par un courrier
à votre prédécesseur le 13 juin et comme
je n'ai pas eu de réponse je l'ai
confirmé par un courrier à vous-même le
20 septembre peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
j'aurai une réponse ça porte sur les
conséquence du DPE sur les petites
surfaces on sait que le les les
nouvelles règles de DPE analyse les
petites surfaces parce que les surfaces
déperditives sont proportionnellement
beaucoup plus importantes que les
surfaces habitables et l'Observatoire
national de la rénovation estime que 63
% des surfaces de moins de 30 m² sont
classé en E F ou G alors que pour
l'ensemble du parc le chiffre est de 39
%. et on a très souvent des
diagnostiqueurs qui préconisent des
solution tout à fait inadaptée pour des
petites surfaces surtout en milieu
urbain quand la seule solution est de
mettre une pompe à chaleur en ville au
premier étage ça pose un certain nombre
de problèmes techniqu de coût
d'urbanisme et d'esthétique mais c'est
très souvent ce qui se passe alors il y
a eu des propositions qui ont été faites
notamment par je crois le syndicat des
diagnostiqueurs qui suggèrent qu'il y
ait un coefficient de pondération pour
les petites surfaces j'aimerais savoir
ce qu'il en est de cette idée qui je
crois a été reprise par certains y
compris au gouvernement et pour terminer
je j'attireraai juste votre attention
sur le fait sur un exemple qui n'était
pas dans ma question orale et donc donc
je viens l'enrichir un de mes amis a mis
en sur un journal d'annonce un studio
àoué en proche banlieu parisienne il a
eu 500 réponses c'est dire combien la
demande de logement est est forte et
qu'il ne me paraît pas très opportun de
continuer à retirer des logements du
marché merci Hervé et merci d'avoir
limité à une seule question ce que va
faire également Vincent capo canela
merci Président je vous confirme euh
monsieur le ministre merci d'abord de de
tout ce que vous nous avez dit et des
intentions que vous avez affiché qui
sont positives euh on cherche tous la
mesure simple efficace qui pourrait
contribuer à relancer la production de
logement et vous avez tout à l'heure
illustré un sujet qui était la hausse
des taux et l'impact sur les accédents
potentiels à la propriété bon alors il y
avait une mesure fiscale qui avait été
mise en place du temps de la loi TEPA
c'était en 2007 alors elle a été en
partie déccriée elle a pas forcément
totalement atteint sa cible à l'époque
mais elle visait à une déduction des
intérêts pour une part en tout cas je
crois c'était de mémoire 40 % la
première année 20 % la 2è pour les
accédentss intérêt des emprun qui éta
qui était de ce fait là déductibleon
alors il faut peut-être la recentrer il
faut peut-être réfléchir à l'impact la
critériser mais est-ce que ça
permettrait pas d'avoir alors je sais
pas si on appellerait ça le le ver Grit
mais une une solution visible simple
efficace qui puisse entraîner il y a
peut-être quelque chose à à regarder en
tout cas on est quelques-uns à être
disponible pour pour en
parler merci Vincent Didier rambau puis
Jean-François rappel merci président
monsieur le ministre centrer mon propos
sur la loi et ru loin de moi de vouloir
remettre en cause cette loi parce qu'au
contraire je considère que la si on a eu
ces dernières années construction d'un
certain nombre de logements sociaux
c'est bien grâce à la loi etud peut-être
d'ailleurs vous auriez des des chiffres
de comparaison enfin nous dire l'impact
de la loi et ses rues sur la
construction de logements sociaux
néanmoins deux deux remarques sur le
problème des des commune dite carencé
dans mon département de liser bon j'ai
pu me rendre compte qu'il y avait
quelques communes carencé et j'estime
que pour certaines d'entre elles ça me
critères d'exemption me paraît me paraît
très injuste je vais citer une commune
parce que je sais qu'elle vient de vous
adresser un recours la commune de
volnavéo qui a rejoint la la métropole
grenobbloise en 2016 a appliqué
parfaitement le PLH de l'agglomération
grenoise mais en l'appliquant ça l'a
fait passer au-delà des 3500 habitants
entre 2000 2020 2022 elle s'est retrouvé
effectivement exempée et aujourd'hui
suite à des changements de critères elle
se retrouve carencée et dev voir une
amende de 70000 €. là c'est c'est un
sujet qui peut faire exploser une équipe
municipale voir la la faire démissionner
comment est-ce que vous par rapport à
cette loi su est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de de revoir un petit peu
ces critères d'exemption et enfin
dernière question qui concerne je
m'excuse le logement étudiants qui est
un sujet essentiel c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de déchecs chez nous étudiant
c'est en raison d'un manque de logement
mais par contre c'est très difficile
pour une collectivité locale d'investir
dans le logement étudiant parce que ça
rapporte rien parce que ça crée des
problèmes aussi de cohabitation de
voisinage et de nombreux recours et
alors là aussi est-ce que les les
logements étudiants peuvent rentrer dans
les quotas de SRU merci merci Didier
Jean François rappin puis Christine
Lavarde monsieur le ministre je serai
très bref d'autant que le rapporteur
général empiété sur mes propos mais
c'est bien normal puisqu'il puisquil
puisqu'il parle il parle en premier
entre Jean-François ça se fait monsieur
le ministre le logement en France c'est
deux jambes c'est un parc social et
public depuis de nombreuses années mais
aussi un parc privé on a vu récemment de
nombreux articles dans la presse
d'inquiétude des promoteurs
privés notamment la Fédération française
des promoteurs immobiliers au travers
son président qui est de notre région et
et moi je je je suis inquiet B regard
alors vous nous avez fait beaucoup
d'annonces là mais simplement sur cette
part privée vous
parlez de la façon dont on pourrait
aborder la question fiscale et de la
défiscalisation dans dans dans le
logement privé au travers une mission
parlementaire moi ce que je ne comprends
pas aujourd'hui et ça n'est pas de votre
fait vous n'étiez pas au manette du
ministère du logement mais on aurait dû
faire ça avant de transformer le pinal
en pinal plus peut-être que l'expertise
aurait dû se fait aurait dû se faire
avant de de de prendre une mesure aussi
radicale dont je l'ai entendu siffler
très
fort de la part des promoteurs de de
toute la France il y a peu de temps donc
je je je pense qu'il faut peut-être il
aurait fallu anticiper un petit peu plus
et donc ma question est simple quel est
l'avenir de la promotion privé en France
au regard du
gouvernement merci Jean-François
Christine Lavarde puis Thierry
KIC oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vais vous
interroger sur la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments il me semble que vous avez
annoncé il y a enfin au début de ce mois
une enveloppe de 1 milliard 2 donc pour
favoriser les opérations de rénovation
de logement alors est-ce que cette
enveloppe sociale oui he mais est-ce que
cette enveloppe c'est celle que vous
considérez obtenir en rendant
obligatoire entre guillemets
l'exonération de taxes foncière pour les
logements socials qui font l'objet de
rénovation je précise que vous laissez
la possibilité aux communes de délibérer
contre cette exonération mais vous
inversez la règle c'està-d qu'avant on
donnait le droit à la commune de
délibérer pour accorder une exonération
désormais l'exonération est de droit et
si la commune ou l'interco ne veut pas
elle va devoir délibérer c'est quand
même pas tout à fait la même chose he et
il me semble pas que c'est cette mesure
a été concertée avec les associations de
collectivité enfin qu'elles l'ont
découverte dans le PLF mais donc est-ce
que c'est un milliard 2 c'est uniquement
ça ou est-ce que vous avez d'autres
enveloppes de crédit ou est-ce que vous
comptez nous en déposer des nouvelles
par amendement au cours de la de la
lecture du
PLF merci Christine Thierry KIC puis
Jean-Marie mizon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
pour la la clarté et les les
perspectives volontaristes que vous nous
donnez moi j'aimerais si vous me le
permettez replacer le débat sur la
focale mettre la focale sur un focus sur
le financement du parc locatif social
euh les difficultés aujourd'hui sur le
marché locatif privé vient d'allonger la
liste d'attente pour un logement social
alors même que 70 % de de la population
est aujourd'hui éligible en 1 an 100000
nouvelles demandes ont été déposées ce
qui porte à 2,3 millions le nombre total
de ménages qui sont en attente
aujourd'hui d'un d'un logement social et
paradoxalement dans le même temps la
production de logements sociaux diminue
avec moins de 100000 agréments en 2022
alors que 120000 étaient
prévu vous le savez la baisse des moyens
des organismes HLM impacte
nécessairement la production de logement
et je voudrais revenir même si vous
n'étiez pas en responsabilité mais la
puissance publique que vous représentez
aujourd'hui je crois aussi une grande
part de de responsabilité notamment je
vrais revenir sur le la baisse des aPL
qui ont eu des effets négatifs et qui
ont obliger les bailleurs à réduire leur
loyer et de fait leurs recettes au
détriment de leur capacité
d'investissement de et de construction
donc pour per les carences de de l'État
un certain nombre de de collectivités
territoriales se sont organisé je vais
citer un cas que je connais bien dans le
département de la Sart qui est qui est
la métropole leement
métropole qui a pris des mesures
importantes en débloquant un fond d'aide
exceptionnel doté de 6 millions d'euros
pour 2023 et 2024 qui vise à débloquer
plus de 400 logements pour leur
permettre de de sortir de
terre est-ce que vous pouvez ça se
termine j'en viens à ma question
monsieur le ministre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter clairement les
mesures financières que vous pourriez
mettre en œuvre afin que les
collectivités ne se retrouvent pas en
première ligne pour pallier les carences
de l'État en matière de logement social
merci Thierry Jean-Marie mizon puis
Stéphane satarel merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre la
question que je voulais vous poser et
que je que je vais vous poser concerne
le prix à tau Z0 il est déjà intervenu à
plusieurs reprises et la réponse que
vous en avez faite à monsieur le
rapporteur général ne m'a pas satisfaite
donc je la repose vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure le prix à zéro en évoquant une
zone son géographique resserré ça
interpelle parce que c'est très c'est
très discriminant et je voulais vous
savoir si vous tiendrez compte des zones
frontalières qui ne sont plus depuis
l'ouverture de l'Europe et
singulièrement depuis Schengen des zones
de
Finistère et parfois ces zones sont
voisins d'un pays où le PIB par habitant
est le plus élevé au monde je parle en
particulier du Luxembourg là aussi il y
a des problèmes de tension entre entre
les pour les acquéreurs ce qui pose de
sérieux difficulté pour les gens
concernés
merci merci Jean-Marie Stéphane satarel
puis Grégory blanc merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre en
essayant d'être synthétique trois trois
constats trois questions néanmoins et et
une remarque les constats c'est malgré
tout aujourd'hui la situation des des
propriétaires la situation des
propriétaires fonciers qui globalement
sont les victimes de la fiscalité et et
de l'accroissement des normes depuis 6
ans et donc on constate aujourd'hui leur
leur désengagement assez large ce qui ce
qui ne manque pas de de poser des
difficultés deuxième élément c'est la
définition du logement social vous
l'avez dit vous-même quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui pratiquement 70 % des de
nos concitoyens peuvent accéder au
logement social on s'interroge sur cette
définition du logement social troisème
remarque sur le lien emploi logement et
covid et qui fera le le lien avec mes
questions en particulier sur le milieu
rural puisqueen milieu rural le lien
emploi logement est évident et avec une
grande proximité et très peu de mobilité
et le covid a redonné un peu d'espoir et
d'attractivité à nos territoires ruraux
or que constate-t-on et ce sont mes
trois questions le zan je reprends la
question de mon voisin qui aujourd'hui
au-delà des aspects financiers sur le
coût d'accès à la propriété pose un
problème simplement d'autorisation
d'urbanisme et va le poser encore
davantage demain quand on ajoute ça au
plui à la loi montagne et à la lecture
extensive que certains peuvent faire de
la loi montagne on s'interroge sur la
réelle capacité à construire et
accueillir sur nos territoires ruraux ou
à garder la population
deuxème question moi ce qui est très
ouverte c'est sur l'innovation
l'innovation sur le logement je
m'interroge si on est à la veille d'une
grande loi notamment sur les questions
de de portage de logement pour favoriser
l'accès à la propriété et enfin une
3oème question c'est une accélération
est-ce que que penseriez-vous d'une
accélération de l'indivision
successorale j'ai pour ma part commis
une PPL sur ce sujetlà qui me paraîtrait
pouvoir régler un certain nombre de
questions et libéré du foncier merci
merci Stéphane grégoryi blanc puis Rémy
Ferrou oui monsieur le ministre par
avance je vous prie de m'excuser je vais
devoir aller en séance donc je vais
poser la question peut-être n'aurais-je
pas le plaisir de de d'écouter votre
réponse mais mes collègues vous la
verrez ensuite vous pourrez la revoir
exactement deux questions synthétiques
la première sur les exconérations de
taxes foncières la deuxième sur le le
zanne sur les exonération de de taxes
foncières les communes de de banlieu
avec qpv vous l'avez souligné sont
celles qui conscentrent le plus souvent
les les précarités à la fois dans le
parc social mais très souvent aussi dans
le parc privé qui lui est
adjacent on a je prends ma commune 42 %
de le logements
sociaux exonération de taxes foncière
1,7 million d'euros non compensé puisque
la compensation est de8000 € pour un
budget de fonctionnement de 18 million
d'euros c'est le cas de toutes les
communes de banlieu or pour rendre
attractif le parc privé il faut aussi
avoir un environnement qui permettent
effectivement de rendre ce parc privé
attractif et c'est le rôle des euh de la
puissance publique communale donc euh
dans ce projet de loi euh comment
comptez-vous effectivement dès à présent
mais peut-être de manière pluriannuelle
discuter avec Bercy pour que les
exonérations de taxes foncières puissent
se faire comme elles devrai euh se faire
euh je le dis parce que euh il va être
soumis euh à notre discussion dans le
premier volet de la loi de finance
une exonération
pour les les bailleurs sociaux qui
s'engageraient dans de la rénovation
thermique et une prolongation de 25 ans
quit de la compensation ça c'était le
premier premier sujet deuxème sujet sur
le zan vous avez évoqué et je termine
monsieur le Président le
plan assez novateur pour les zones
commercial où on s'engage dans le cadre
d'une expérimentation et vers la
déspécialisation qui il faut si on repon
pas notre façon d'aménager le territoire
effectivement on ne pourra pas mettre le
zan en place ça ne passera pas ma
question est la suivante comptez-vous
avoir des expérimentations aussi pour
les zones économique de nos
territoires merci
grégoryi nous passons à Rémi
Ferraud merci monsieur le Président
merci à Monsieur le Ministre le
Rapporteur général a pas empiété sur ma
question mais il l'a devancé donc je ne
vais pas la répéter sur la fiscalité des
différents formes de location et
notamment des meublés touristiques
simplement laissez-moi dire nous avons
vu votre volontarisme monsieur le
ministre dans votre interview au Monde
je crois que c'était au début du mois
d'octobre nous
voyons forme de procrastination du
gouvernement dans son ensemble qui
renvoie à plus tard la crise du logement
elle elle va vite elle continue j'espère
que nous pourrons vous aider à avancer
vraiment et avancer le plus vite
possible dans la discussion budgétaire
au Sénat ensemble parce que cette
question qui concernait particulièrement
le territoire parisien touche
aujourd'hui l'ensemble du territoire
national et frappe très durement
certaines régions touristiques donc
j'espère que nous pourrons avancer
vite merci Rémi MarieClaire CARG puis
jean-rmond
hugounet merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président très rapidement en 2017 le
gouvernement a a
bousculé la la fiscalité relative de des
revenus du capital et de
l'investissement
locatif avec la flat taxe est-ce que
vous envisagé de revenir sur ce choix
qui a été fondamental en 2017 une
deuxème question je suis sénatrice zone
abis donc heureuse bénéficiaire de du
recentrage à Paris du recentrage du PTZ
sauf erreur de ma part le plafond PTZ
enfin le PTZ à Paris ou à Boulogne che
ma
voisine c'est
euh uniquement du neuf à Paris
ça restera on est peut-être il y a
peut-être des millions de gens qui sont
potentiellement bénéficiaires mais le 9
il y en a pas beaucoup et euh le plafond
pour un studio si j'ai bien compris s
Faur de ma part là encore c'est 150000 €
donc
euh 150000 € dans le neuf à Paris déjà
j'ai cherché dans l'ancien au-dessus de
15 m² j'ai trouvé 20 apparts mais dans
le 9U il y en a zéro hein donc je je ne
sais pas quelle est la à qui ça
s'adresse vraiment merci
beaucoup merci MarieClaire jean-rmond
Hugonet puis Christian Klinger merci
président bonjour monsieur le ministre
on en a pris l'habitude maintenant dès
qu'un un sujet majeur ou un problème
majeur arrive on entend parler d'un
grand plan et généralement on est déçu
et c'est encore une fois pas votre
volonté votre capacité votre énergie qui
est en cause mais on est déçu et ces
grands plans à couche de mesure
technique pour lesquelles d'ailleurs les
professionnels j'ai eu l'occasion de de
discuter longuement la semaine dernière
avec Véronique
Bedag qui construit
elle sont généralement également
critiques et on a l'impression vraiment
de deux mondes qui ne se parl pas
forcément ou en tout cas quand ils se
parlent ne s'entendent pas alors par
rapport à cette remarque je voulais
rebondir sur une seconde remarque de
notre collègue Didier rambau je ne
partage pas bien évidemment sa de la loi
etu et mais lui dire que ce genre de
situation kafcayenne qu'il connaît et
qui est une des hérésies de la loi etu
et bien est partagé dans nombre de
départements en tout cas dans le mien on
a quelques caricatures aussi ma question
est la suivante vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure dans votre propos introductif de
de débat avec les
collectivités sur l'aide à la pierre
notamment donc le débat avec les
collectivité jusqu'ici vous en avez
parlé aussi il était dans le rapport des
contrats de mixité soci
sur lesquels notre collègue et ami
Dominique estrasson a été
particulièrement allente ici au Sénat on
a vu pousser quelque chose début octobre
poussé par madame la Première ministre
sur les contrats territoriaux qui visent
cette fois-ci les
intercommunalité alors monsieur le
ministre il est très clair avec pour
corollire les courriers de notre préfet
je ne sais pas si dans les autres
départements ça a été la même chose mais
un préfet vous écrivant le 15 octobre
avec une réponse souhaitée pour le 19
octobre pour l'engagement des des
intercommunalités juste vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre que dans ce pays et
ici au Sénat les seules collectivités de
plein exercice sont les communes les
intercommunalités ne le sont pas et j'ai
entendu parler de plui oui il y a des
plui et là où les collectivités veulent
faire des plui elles le font et c'est
très bien mais c'est pas encore la norme
dans notre pays voilà pourquoi
j'aimerais vous entendre sur ces
contrats territoriaux
merci jean-rmond Christian Klinger puis
Frédéric Espagnac merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre ma
question sera très brève puisquelle a
déjà été on va dire abordée par certains
certain nombre de collègues quand
allez-vous revoir le statut fiscal des
bailleurs privés c'est le seul moyen
pour faire revenir les investissements
privés dans la
construction beaucoup de de personnes
privées n'iront plus ou ne vont pas
aller dans dans ce type d'investissement
la rentabilité est trop faible si demain
vous le vous l'adaptez au statut du LMNP
je suis certain que le lendemain vous
avez la construction qui repart avec
certainement de
chiffres merci mais vous aurz des
problèmes avec votre collègue de
berc merci Christian de faire les
questions et les
réponses frééri Espagnac puis Laurent
saum oui monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre merci juste d'abord
peut-être par vous remercier puisque
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre donc
vous remercier puisque vous étiez venu
fin août à bunus dans le Pays-Basque
suite au lendemain de votre prise de
fonction vous étiez engagé sur notamment
l'acceptation de la demande de la gllo
au Pays-Bas sur l'ENC demand des loyers
vous avez fait donc une annonce ces
derniers jours donc je tenais à vous
remercier pour avoir tenu parole et
engagement rapides le deuxième
évidemment je faisait partie de la
commission qui avait été mis en place
par votre prédécesseur sur la trtion des
logements en zone tendu vous savez à
quel point cette situation est urgente
nous avons évoqué les uns et les autres
le littoral la montagne et même en
montagne il faut gérer l'activité
économisation de ski mais aussi veiller
au logement des autochtones donc nous en
parlerons avec l'ANEM et avec les autres
associations l'urgence évidemment sur la
loiak Chanis vous autoriserez des
Pyrenées atlantiqu et an glemer
évidemment et je sais que à quel point
vous travaillez avec eux une autre un
autre sujet puisque en complément vous
savez à quel point le littoral
atlantique aujourd'hui est prisé
notamment la côte basque et on a aussi
sur la question du de de la vente et des
plusvalues une transformation régulière
des résidences secondaires en résidences
principal pour éviter évidemment cette
taxation et donc il y a urgence puisque
là aussi les conséquences ne serit- que
pour les collectivités avec le prix des
domaines et autres sont majeur et donc
c'est en ça que nous avons aussi besoin
de mesures sur ce sujet-là
merci merci Frédéric Laurence saum oui
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
Ministre l'année dernière 150000 postes
étaient ouverts pour les saisonniers et
seulement 50 % ont pu trouver un
logement euh il bien sûr c'est corrélé
avec la régulation des logements
touristiques est-ce que vous quelles
sont les mesures que le
Gouvernement envisage de prendre ou en
tout cas les pistes de réflexion qu'il a
à la fois sur cette régulation du
logement touristique et les mesures pour
atténuer je dirais les locations courte
durée qui rendent beaucoup plus cher le
logement et comment résoudre le problème
du logement des saisonniers et deuxème
point c'est on observe dans les
territoires beaucoup de difficultés avec
l'ANA pour les financements des
rénovations et notamment des rénovations
lourdes pour les personnes très
précaires quelle mesure pensez-vous
prendre pour accélérer ces circuits de
d'instruction et surtout de
financement merci Laurent et nous en
avons terminé avec les questions et je
remercie les trois ou quatre qui n'en
ont pas posé ça vous permettra monsieur
le ministre de disposer d'un peu plus de
temps pour répondre à l'ensemble de ces
16 questions
merci en tout cas une remarque globale
l'ensemble de ces de vos interventions
montre je trouve la diversité des
situations du logement sur les
différents territoires que vous
représentez et montre à quel point la
décentralisation de la politique du
logement et la différenciation de
l'action de l'État en fonction de
territoire est vitale et tout à l'heure
quand j'ai
évoqué la loi logement si je l'ai
qualifia de grande veuillez me pardonner
elle sera pas plus grande que les autres
ce que je voulais dire simplement c'est
parce que j'avais repris l'expression du
du président de la République c'était
l'idée du loi logement justement qui
doit repenser ça comme ça et qui doit
repenser cette réalité d'aujourd'hui qui
fait que la politique du logement par
territoire elle doit être maintenant
très fortement différencié et ça je
pense que vos interventions successives
me l'ont encore encore plus encore plus
prouvé je reviens sur vos sur vos
questions la première sur le le le zan
[Musique]
euh je
je tout à l'heure je l'évoqua quand on
évoquait les les différentes crises dans
lequel on se situe aujourd'hui il y a
certes une crise de la production il y a
aussi une crise environnementale
indéniable je vais pas ici faire un un
un speech sur sur le zan vous l'avez
déjà fait main fois la France a consommé
de manière excessive le foncier vous le
savez largement plus que nos voisins
aujourd'hui et la question du nouveau
modèle de développement territorial qu'
doit qui ne peut plus être celui du
passé nous ne pouvons plus continuer à
consommer le foncier comme nous l'avons
fait au cours des 50 dernières années
nous ne pouvons plus nous avons une
urgence environnementale devant nous qui
nécessite de repenser modèle de
développement territorial c'est la
raison pour laquelle je disait
aujourd'hui les outils ne sont plus
adaptés parce que nos outils
d'aujourd'hui de la politique du
logement correspondent à ce modèle de
développement territorial ancien qui est
un modèle de consommation foncière et
donc quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
la loi logement ce qu'on doit faire
ensemble parce que vous jouerez un rôle
clé dans cette loi logement là c'est
comment on repense justement nos outils
de la politique du logement pour
correspondre à ces nouveaux enjeux
comment ont réussit à privil à à faire
émerger je donne qu'un exemple vous avez
aujourd'hui des territoires qui
connaissent de très fortes vacances de
logement aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de
bons outils adaptés pour répondre à ces
enjeux aujourd'hui et ça existe dans les
petites villes ça existe dans les villes
moyennes ça existe dans la ruralité
aujourd'hui on a des réalités de
vacances on a des réalités de d Creus
quand on analyse aujourd'hui les outils
dont nous disposons pour aborder ces
sujets là nous n'en avons pas nous n'en
avons pas les outils que nous avons on
privilégié par le passé du développement
du neuf à côté de la vacance et donc
aujourd'hui comme on doit on doit
changer notre modèle de développement
territorial mais qu'on a des outils de
l'ancien monde j'ai envie de dire
presque et ben ça va pas ça va pas et du
coup la tentation c'est de dire mais
remettons ces outils-là mais ces
outils-là ne correspondent plus à cette
multicrise donc il y a des nouveaux
outils à inventés il s'agit pas
d'opposer en fait la la ruralité à à à
la ville il s'agit pas d'opposer les
petites villes aux métropole il y a des
réalités diverses qui nécessitent des
outils diverses là où il faudra mettre
l'accent sur le recyclage foncier làù il
faudra mettre l'accent sur la capacité à
regagner de la vacance de l'autre côté
il faudra privilégier le neuf et
effectivement du coup à Paris oui le PTZ
il est sur le 9 parce qu'à Paris ce dont
on a besoin c'est du U et là où le PTZ
est dans l'ancien sur la rénovation oui
exactement il y a des enjeux financiers
derrière tout ça vous avez raison et
donc il faut qu'on repense nos outils de
la politique du logement y compris nos
outils financier pour pouvoir vous avez
raison faire ça c'est plus cher c'est
plus complexe ça demande plus
d'ingénierie et aujourd'hui on l'a pas
et donc tout tout toute la ce qu'on va
devoir réussir à construire ensemble
c'est c'est outils là qui correspondent
à cette réalité du nouveau modèle de
développement territorial donc je
partage complètement ce que vous avez
dit les outils n'existe pas aujourd'hui
il faut les inventer le fond Frich est
un début le fond friche est un début je
trouve qu'il il imprime une nouvelle
façon effectivement d'aborder le modèle
de développement territorial moi je me
réjouis je suis aussi élu local à un
moment donné et ça a correspondu à un
certain nombre
d'enjeux la sortie des passoirs
thermique juste un mot on on parle de
673000 logements du parc locatif privé
aujourd'hui qui sont en G dont 133000
logements de ce parc privé qui donc qui
sont aujourd'hui en G+ c'est-à-dire déjà
entre guillemets interdits ils sont
encore loués d'ailleurs parce que vous
connaissez le le système ce n'est pas
une interdiction de location c'est une
évolution des critères de la descence
qui permet au locataire d'attaquer en
justice le propriétaire donc c'est
beaucoup plus subtil oui mais de fait
ils sont encore loués et ça ne commence
qu'à la relocation et donc aujourd'hui
la majorité de ces logements aujourd'hui
n'ont pas encore été reloués et donc
effectivement c'est pour ça encore qui
sont
encore aujourd'hui ce que ce que je dis
par rapport à cette sortie des passoirs
c'est nous ne voulons pas la sortie de
ces passoirs personne ne souhaite la
sortie de ces passoirs thermiques mais
nous voulons avec les professionnels de
l'immobilier que les travaux se fassent
y a-t-il besoin de travaux de
copropriété pour les logements eners
loui aujourd'hui ou pas est- est-ce
qu'il a besoin de travaux de copropriété
s'il y a besoin de travaux de
copropriété effectivement le calendrier
du 1er j janvier 2025 pardon sera sans
doute difficile à tenir faut-il encore
que la copropriété soit d'accord pour le
faire mais les premiers chiffres qui me
remonte c'est que 90 % des logements
concernés ne nécessitent pas de travaux
de copropriété pour passer de G en F et
des travaux qui ne nécessitent pas des
travaux de copropriété ça peut être fait
ça peut être fait nous avons renforcer
le dispositif maprime Renov qui
s'adresse au bailleur nous avons permis
mon accompagnateur Renov qui permet
d'accompagner sur les dossiers
administratifs et ceter je suis d'accord
et plusieurs vous plusieurs d'entre vous
l'ont dit c'est encore complexe je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord moi je trouve
aussi que c'est complexe je n'arrête pas
de le dire à mon cabinet c'est pour ça
que je suis regardé je trouve que les
dispositifs aujourd'hui c'est encore
complexe autour des aides de l'ANA je
vais je vais je vais vous illustrer je
suis allé je suis allé à à Lille à un
moment donné doné pour justement montrer
une opération exemplaire de rénovation
le brri a été interrogé le premier mot
qui on lui a dit alors ça s'est passé
comment le premier mot qu'il a dit c'est
compliqué pourtant c'était exemplaire il
était du du monde du bâtiment et cetera
donc nous travaillons et je veux que
nous travaillons encore à la
simplification de ces choses renforcer
la formation des accompagnateurs
renforcer aussi le nombre
d'accompagnateurs moi à ner parce que
aussi quelques fonctions là-bas j'ai eu
du mal à recruter mes diagnostiqueurs
que je fournis gratuitement à la
population communauté urbaine de duner
fournis gratuitement la population des
diagnostiqueurs j'ai eu du mal à les
recruter donc il y a aussi des problèmes
de recrutement dans ces accompagnateurs
on doit pouvoir faire mieux sur
l'accompagnement mais ce que je veux
simplement dire c'est aujourd'hui
fixons-nous collectivement un objectif
essayons d'accompagner au mieux ces
propriétaires bailleurs financièrement
et en terme d'accompagnement technique
et accompagnement administratif pour
qu'il fassent les travaux et surtout à 1
an et 2 mois du gong ne disons pas trop
vite allez on laisse tomber 2025 on
reporte en 2028 parce que je vous fais
le Paris qu'en 2025 on se retrouve tous
au même endroit et les travaux ont été
faits de la même manière et on se posera
toujours la même question donc je
voudrais sur les passoires thermiques
qu'on reste encore dans une logique de
faire et on fera le point à un moment
donné on fera le point mais on est dans
une logique de faire on pousse à faire
d'ailleurs je je travaille avec les
professionnels de l'immobilier justement
pour que l'afnaim l'UNICE et cetera
puisse davantage avoir une plusvalue sur
cet accompagnement mais je continue à
être volontarist sur cette
question sur le coefficient de
pondération ah du DPE pardon oui je
l'avais noté après alors sur le sur le
DPE je partage avec vous l'idée que sur
les petites surfaces nous devons
continuer à à à travailler alors je avec
Christoph Béchu on travaille sur
l'évolution du DPE il y a une réunion
d'ailleurs ce soir sur cette
question je pense que c'est sur les
petites surfaces qu'on peut essayer
d'améliorer les choses je pense qu'il
faut pas remettre tout le dispositif en
cause parce que certains ont la
tentation de tout remettre en cause mais
par contre je suis d'accord avec vous
nous cherchons à faire évoluer le
dispositif sur les petites surfaces où
je pense qu'il y a un problème donc je
je reconnais ce que vous avez
évoqué sur le prêt à taux zéro de de
deux remarques ont été faites je voulais
juste revenir sur le sur le pourcentage
qui a été donné parce que 6 millions
c'est le nombre de
d'éligibles mais si on prend le nombre
de vente en fait on a 350000 vente
aujourd'hui en France dont 120000 en
bloc ce qui fait 230000 ventes sur ces
230000 V
40000 PTZ ou 45000 PTZ ça représente au
autour de 18 20 % ce qui me semble être
pas si mal et quant au au au PTZ sur
Paris simplement une chose d'abord le
PTZ il a pas vocation à couvrir la
totalité du prêt c'est un avantage et
sur Paris c'est un avantage à peu près
de 20000 € dans l'acquisition donc le
PTZ il peut être complété par un autre
prêt vous avez pas besoin de de le
plafond c'est le plafond du PTZ c'est
pas le plafond de l'acquisition donc
là-dessus il y il y a pas de souci par
rapport au au au PTZ euh qui qui
aujourd'hui mais je le rappelle n'a
jamais été aussi incitatif avec des taux
à 4,2 % un prêt à taux zéro aujourd'hui
c'est une obben exceptionnelle quand on
avait du 1,2 % le prêt à taux zéro
finalement était pas si bénéfique que ça
aujourd'hui vous avez un prêt à tau 0 à
42 qui est très bénéfique donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il est largement
renforcé
[Musique]
euh les mesures de la loi TPA euh
globalement les retours qui en a c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs que la la mesure
a été finalement arrêtée c'est qu'elle
est finalement assez chè avec un impact
qui a pas été du tout à la hauteur du
coût et c'est vrai que c'est une mesure
particulièrement onéreuse alors vous
l'avez évoqué sur le le le
resserrage et le recentrage pardon et et
autres mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les retours sont plutôt assez négatifs
ça va pas produit en fait plus pour le
logement ça a été une obè en terme de
pouvoir d'achat mais pas forcément en
fait une ça n'a pas forcément généré
plus de production de logement que ça en
tout cas c'est les premières études
d'impact là-dessus sur la loi
SRU la moitié des logements produits
logements sociaux pardon produits
aujourd'hui vient de la loi s voilà donc
ça la loi SRE aujourd'hui a un impact
énorme sur la production de logements
sociaux et si nous n'avions pas la loi
SRU aujourd'hui je pense que on serait
en très grande difficulté sur la
production de logement social donc la
loi SRU elle est un élément essentiel de
la production de logement social
aujourd'hui un sur de je crois que c'est
43 % pour l'année passée mais c'est un
sur de en moyenne si on prend les
dernières années donc c'est un élément
essentiel je veux vous savez tous J'ai
j'étais le Conseiller de Claude
bartelogne qui a coécrit cet article 55
de la loi su en son temps vous le savez
pas je pas le cacher je tiens beaucoup à
cette loi je trouve qu'elle a non
seulement des vertus en termees de
production de de logement social mais
elle a également des vertus qui nous
permettent de rééquilibrer à l'échelle
de l'agglomération est-ce qu'elle est
parfaite
non et chacun d'entre nous chacun
d'entre nous pour des raisons diverses
je pourrait même le dire moi sur
dunkererque chacun d'entre nous aurait
probablement des raisons d'IR
toucher mais j'ai plutôt envie de la
défendre j'ai plutôt envie de la
défendre parce qu'elle est tellement
structurante pour le logement social
aujourd'hui en
France elle est tellement importante
aujourd'hui pour le rééquilibrage de la
production de logements sociaux que
toucher y toucher c'est ouvrir une boîte
de pendor qui me semble dangereuse si on
veut pouvoir continuer demain au moment
de la crise de la production si on
touche en plus à cette loi là demain je
pense que ça peut avoir des conséquences
très néfastes est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il
faut améliorer des choses sans doute
peut-être on peut toujours améliorer des
choses mais je voudrais d'abord
commencer par la défendre et par dire à
quel point elle est importante pour nous
aujourd'hui est-ce que les logements
étudiants sont dans le cota etu la Rép
oui les logements étudiants sont dans le
quotau aujourd'hui donc il n'y a pas de
de souci par rapport à à
ça j'avais une autre question sur les
su je vais sans doute y revenir plus
tard je suis désolé j'ai perdu le fil
sur la question de de l'inquiétude des
des promoteurs et sur le Pinel et la
prépinel je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
cette crise de la production de logement
on l'a vu arriver
on l'a vu arriver quand dans les
métropoles on s'est aperçu que 70 % 80 %
finissaient parêtre des logements
dispositif d fiscalinestissement locatif
on a compris à ce moment-l que les prix
immobiliers avait décroché de la
capacité
d' pour accéder de nos concitoyens et
que finalement on était à travers un
dispositif d' fiscale en train de doper
la demande et donc de doper
artificiellement les prix on l'a vu
arriver ça le Pinel quelque part a
permis de retarder l'échéance et a
permis de rajouter cette couche de
croissance des prix immobiliers donc des
prix fonciers qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
est encore plus haut dans la crise et ça
on l'a bien vu arriver et donc on
pourrait répondre en disant finalement
bah on en remet encore un on en remet
encore un encore plus parce qu'il va
falloir monter les prix là maintenant
parce que avec avec les taux d'intérêt
là l'accession est encore plus en PNE et
et on va remonter comme ça ça les prix
immobiliers et continuer à doper
artificiellement la demande sur la base
d'une stratégie fiscale mais où on va
après où on va après c'est est-ce que le
moment n'est pas de s'interroger sur ces
boosters un peu artificiels de la
demande et à un moment donné de faire
reposer la politique du logement sur des
bases beaucoup plus saines et beaucoup
plus stables parce que quand on est à 70
% ou 80 % en métropole fondé sur du
dispositif dête fiscale il y a quelque
chose qui va plus dans le pays quand on
a 178 % de croissance des prix
immobiliers
plus de 200 % dans le centre-ville des
grandes villes et que le pouvoir d'achat
immobilier des ménages a totalement
décroché quand vous regardez la
croissance des deux c'est totalement
décroché B on s'expose effectivement un
risque sur le taux d'intérêt et une
simple remontée du taux d'intérêt à un
moment donné et ben voilà on est dans le
système et la crise est totale et donc
je je pense oui il faut inventer des
choses et j'ai effectivement essayé je
ne crois pas au dispositif unique
magique je crois qu'il faut retravailler
l'ensemble de de la demande c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé logement locatif
social j'ai parlé investissement locatif
j'ai parlé accession à la propriété j'ai
évoqué la question du foncier
aujourd'hui qui est une question
centrale on la peut évoquer j'ai évoqué
la question du logement locatif
intermédiaire je pense qu'il faut
travailler je pense qu'il faut
travailler sur l'ensemble aujourd'hui
des éléments de la demande sans doute
travailler à des choses qui seront
provisoires c'est vrai parce que on ne
peut pas accepter aujourd'hui
l'effondrement de l'appareil de
production ce serait trop dangereux pour
notre pays parce qu'on mettrait 10 ans à
le à le reconstruire cet appareil de
production et et en même temps il faut
assaignir les prix immobiliers qui sont
aujourd'hui délirants et qui en tout cas
ne correspondent plus au pouvoir d'achat
immobilier des ménages et qui ont exclu
de l'accession à la propriété une grande
partie de nos concitoyens et donc si on
veut à un moment donné recalibrer et
remettre les prix à la bonne hauteur il
nous faut être suffisamment fin j'ai
envie de dire nos aides et en
accompagnement de cette crise pour ne
pas utiliser les remèdes d'avant qui
n'ont fait qu'amplifier la crise
d'aujourd'hui finalement et retarder les
choses c'est donner à nos successeurs
finalement la la crise encore plus
importante du logement dans 2 ou 3 ans
je suis pas sûr que ce soit ce que vous
souhaitez collectivement et c'est ce à
quoi j'essaie de de
m'attacher je continue sur les
rénovations thermiques dans le logement
locatif social les 1,2 milliards c'est
donc un fond d'aide direct apporté par
l'État aux bailleurs sociaux pour
accompagner la rénovation énergétique
des logements locatifs sociaux voilà sur
l'exoe TFPB oui on a enversé c'est la
charge de la preuve mais les communes
ont toujours la possibilité de de s'en
extraire si ell si elles le souhaitent
sur le parc social on m'a posé aussi la
question de des
collectivités
locales des alors d'abord oui le parc
social et c'est une nouveauté de cette
crise le secteur du logement locatif
social pardon c'est une nouveauté de
criise n'est plus contracyclique mais
procyclique
jusqu'à présent le logement social a
servi d'amortisseur aux
crise parce que les bailleurs sociaux
avaient leur propre capacité de
production de logement parce que
l'équilibre des opérations n'était pas
forcément reposé forcément sur beaucoup
de de vente HLM aujourd'hui avec plus de
ventes dans l'équilibre des opérations
et avec 50 % en
VEFA le secteur du logement social est
aujourd'hui procyclique c'està-dire que
quand le pré est en crise le logement
social est en crise aussi ça c'est une
nouveauté de cette crise qui vient de
l'évolution en fait de la production du
logement social en France et donc
effectivement la crise est double
elle y a pas il y a pas l'effet
contracyclique naturel d'un secteur qui
pourrait être autonome du privé et donc
effectivement moins de production de
logement social augmentation du nombre
de demandeurs je mets juste un un bémol
je sais plus qui l'a évoqué 2,3
millions de demandeurs
800 1000 sont déjà dans le parc locatif
social ce qui pose aussi une question de
mobilité à l'intérieur du parc social
qui est devenu absolument essentiel et
qui pose la question de la
sous-occupation des grands logements qui
pose beaucoup de questions derrière
cette question de la mobilité de
l'accompagnement de la mobilité il y a
des bailleurs sociaux exemplaire pour
accompagner la mobilité il y en a qui le
sont moins aujourd'hui et je l'ai dit
dans mon discours du Congrès HLM il est
important aussi que dans chez les
bailleurs sociaux on s'appuie sur les
bonnes pratiques pour améliorer la
mobilité à l'intérieur du parc si on
veut faire baisser le nombre de
demandeurs il y a un/ers des demandeurs
qui sont liés à la mobilité interne
quand même et un/ers c'est beaucoup et
donc je pense qu'effectivement il faut
aussi l'entendre néanmoins la production
deement social est un enjeu la question
des collectivités locales aujourd'hui je
crois que ça a été évoqué par plusieurs
d'entre
vous ça doit être un sujet de de de de
de la décentralisation de la politique
du logement ça doit être un sujet euh
est-ce que les collectivités locales
aujourd'hui ont pas un rôle plus
important à jouer en matière de
production de logement social je je je
pose la question aujourd'hui alors ça
pose la question de la ressource on est
d'accord je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
collectivités sont mieux placées mais
évidemment il y a la question de la
ressource et donc c'est sans doute cette
question de la ressource qui doit
arriver dans la loi de la
décentralisation qu'est-ce qu'on donne
comme ressource aux collectivités locale
pour rassurer cette compétence de la
décentralisation mais est-ce que si on
trouve cette nouvelle ressource et si on
est d'accord collectivement au niveau du
Parlement pour donner une ressource qui
correspond à cette nouvelle politique et
bien c'est pas à elle justement
d'assumer aussi une part de la
production de lement sociale quand on
parlait du FNAP tout à l'heure est-ce
que c'est pas aussi ça cette idée
derrière le le prê à tau zéro sur les
territoires transfrontalier est-ce qu'on
intègre ce périmètre dans la tension oui
oui oui et d'ailleurs vous avez vu on a
fait un un décret pour modifier les
périmètres lié à la tension et
évidemment la question du
transfrontalier des territoires
transfrontaliers en tension c'est bien
intégré on le sait d'ailleurs
particulièrement bien dans le jeun voie
français mais il y a pas que là et
effectivement c'est bien c'est bien
intégré
euh des innovations pour accéder à la
propriété oui alors le bail réel
solidaire a été innovation une
innovation qui venait d'ailleurs des
notaires j'avais proposé d'ailleurs un
un modèle un peu original également
j'avais proposé à Bruno l ma c'est je
crois dans le système suisse aujourd'hui
vous pouvez imaginer finalement sur les
murs un prê à 25 ans et sur le foncier
un prê à durée
infinie qui n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui dans notre législation euh
bancaire mais je crois que d'autres pays
le font ce qui permet de diminuer
finalement assez fortement la mensualité
de l'accession à la propriété et
finalement vous êtes réellement accéd
dans ça encore mieux que le bail réel et
solidaire parce que vous possédez le
foncier simplement vous ne remboursez
pas le capital sur le foncier et j'avais
proposé ça bon je je je je crois que ça
restera dans les cartons des innovations
possibles un jour néanmoins je voulais
vous le dire donc effectivement trouver
des innovations financières pour
accompagner l'accession à la propriété
de nos concitoyens je pense
qu'effectivement on doit continuer à y
réfléchir et je suis évidemment preneur
de toutes les de toutes les idées euh la
compensation de la dfpb est-ce qu'on
aura la la la le même type
d'expérimentation dans les zones
d'activité économique que dans les zones
commerciales c'est mon souhait
effectivement de continuer à travailler
je pense qu'il faut repenser la mixité
fonctionnelle à l'échelle de la ville et
explorer tous les fonciers disponibles
ah oui j'eneviens à la question des
meublés touristiques et de la fiscalité
sur les meublés touristiques bon euh
vous l'avez dit je m'étais exprimé en
effet dans dans dans le monde là-dessus
euh je pense je je pense qu'il y a il y
a deux choses à
faire d'abord la la question de la
fiscalité ne règlera pas le problème et
il faut qu'on en soit
conscient la fiscalité ne résoudra pas
l'attractivité des meublés touristiques
parce
que la la rentabilité de ce type de
opération est trop forte et donc même si
on rééquilibre la fiscalité demain on
aura toujours une forte attractivité des
meublés touristiqu ça suppose donc qu'il
faut faire émerger un outil de
régulation publique c'est-à-dire il faut
donner à nos communes la possibilité de
pouvoir réguler le marché des meublés
touristiqu aujourd'hui il existe la
compensation la compensation ne me
semble pas aujourd'hui une mesure
suffisante à la disposition de nos
collectivités pour régler réguler pardon
un marché qui a besoin d'être régulé par
par no
Mair et donc j'ai rencontré
effectivement inignaki et Chanis et Anaï
glommer récemment il il souhaitent
porter à travers leur proposition de loi
qui doit arriver à la fin de l'année ou
au début de l'année prochaine il
souhaitent proposer un nouveau un nouvel
outil de régulation à la disposition des
communes du coup ceux qui sont
confrontés au problèmes pourront s'en
saisir et les communes qui estiment
qu'il n'a pas à à être régulé sur leur
territoire parce que justement ils sont
intéressés au développement de meublés
touristique par exemple parce qu'il y
aurait de la vacance benah ne
l'utiliseront pas et donc ça permettra
d'adapter effectivement la façon de
travailler sur l'attractivité des
meublés touristiques en
fonction du du de la spécificité de de
la commune je crois fortement à cet
outil de régulation qui irait plus loin
effectivement que la compensation si je
prends qu'un exemple Saint-Malo il y a
un système de quota qui a été mis en
place je crains que malheureusement
finalement le système aujour aujourd'hui
en place le système législatif juridique
fera que la commune n sans doute pas
appuyé d'ailleurs ils sont attaqués en
justice sur ce sur ce quota si demain
nous arrivions à mettre en place ce
dispositif qui permet par exemple aux
communes de donner un agrément ou de ou
de mettre des quotas et ben là on aurait
effectivement un outil qui permettrait
de régler le problème des meublés
touristiques ensuite viendrait la
question de la fiscalité qui me semble
être notamment pour les parlementaires
une question de justice fiscale et sur
la question de la fiscalité j'en veux
dire la question qui vous est posée en
tant que parlementaire c'est est-ce
qu'il est juste que quelqu'un qui loue
en meublé touristique ou pas touristique
d'ailleurs est 50 % d'abattement et que
celui qui loue en location nu est 30 %
d'abattement c'est une question qui vous
est posée en tant que parlementaire et
qui me semble relev de la justice
fiscale plus que de l'efficacité de la
régulation et donc pour moi je distingue
deux temps quelque chose qui doit
arriver si possible au premier trimestre
2024 qui est un outil de régulation
supplémentaire pour nos collectivités
pour arrêter là où c'est nécessaire le
développement des meublés touristiques
pour celles qui le souhaitent et puis
celles qui le souhaitent pas ok et
ensuite à travers la mission
parlementaire consacrée à la fiscalité
locative vous permettre un débat
parlementaire sain et calme et à tête
reposé sur qu'est-ce qui est juste en
terme de fiscalité
locative sur la question
euh je je vais je peux pas répondre à
tout euh euh je ah oui sur le encore sur
le grand plan qui qui qui accouche de
mesures
techniques je je le redis mais
l'objectif de la loi logement du
printemps 2024 n'est pas un grand plan
qui accouche de mesures techniques c'est
vraiment pas du tout l'objectif
l'objectif c'est juste j'insiste
là-dessus peut-être un peu trop mais
c'est de se dire nous n'avons plus
aujourd'hui des outils de politique de
logement qui correspondent au modèle de
développement territorial nécessaire à à
nos territoires qui soi ruraux ou
urbains nous n'avons plus les bons
outils ils ne correspondent pas on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure quand on
évoquait le zan l'impact le besoin de
nouveaux outils de recyclage foncier
urbain et cetera je pense que nous
n'avons pas les bons outils l'idée de la
loi logement c'est pas un grand plan qui
accouche d'une souris c'est c'est l'idée
de de reposer la question de nos outils
de quoi avons-nous besoin dans les
différents territoires aujourd'hui pour
répondre à la question du logement et je
pense aujourd'hui que les outils de la
politique du logement ne correspondent
plus à ces enjeux et vous l'avez très
bien dit quand vous évoqué le zan tout à
l'heure je pense qu'on a pas on a on a
fait le zan mais maintenant il faut
faire les outils qui vont avec et il
faut il faut y répondre et qui
correspondre à ce nouveau modèle donc
c'est ça l'idée de la loi logement c'est
on réactualise on révise on refonde une
politique du logement davantage adapté à
à ce qu'a besoin le le 21e siècle la
question des conventions
territorialisées versus les contrats de
mixité alors les contrats de mixité
sociale c'est pour les communes carencé
dans la loi
SRU les conventions territorialisées
c'est autre chose quand j'étais au au
Congrès HLM on on m'a souvent posé la
question alors c'est quoi votre grand
objectif national de nombre de logements
sociaux qu'il faut faire de nombre de
logements qu'il faut construire et
cetera et j'avoue j'ai toujours balayé
d'un revers de main cette question du
nombre de logements qu'il fallait
construire à l'échelle nationale parce
que pour moi la seule réalité est une
réalité territoriale c'est-à-dire il y a
des logements à construire à l'échelle
d'un bassin d'habitat il y a pas des
logements à construire à l'échelle
nationale d'ailleurs si on poussait le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout on a autant
de ménage que de logement à l'échelle
nationale donc quelque part on pourrait
en conclure qu'on a pas besoin de
logement demander aux grandes métropoes
ou aux zones touristiques ou dans un
territoire comme ttiner en train de se
réindustrialiser s'il y a pas besoin de
logement ça fera sourire donc on voit
bien que raisonner à l'échelle nationale
n'a plus de sens en terme de production
de logement et donc j'ai renvoyé au
territoire avec un S l'idée de prendre
des engagements en terme de production
de logements sociaux en terme de
rénovation de logements sociaux en terme
de présence de personnel de proximité
parce que je pense que c'est aussi
important vous savez qu'il existe un
décret gardien
de Marie Noel linman qui dit que les log
les bailleurs sociaux doivent mettre un
gardien pour son logement il n'est pas
effacé de d'utres législation
aujourd'hui et donc on est en train de
faire l'évaluation de l'application de
ce décret gardien aujourd'hui donc pour
pour les bailleurs sociaux qui ne
respecterit pas quel engagement il
prennent de présence de personnel de
proximité ce qui me semble absolument
essentiel et d'engagement autour de la
mobilité ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure quand je disais qu'il y avait
800000 demandeurs du du parc social
aujourd'hui qui étaient à l'intérieur du
parc donc quels engagements des
bailleurs sur ces quatre points l'idée
c'était de renvoyer à des conventions
territorialisées les engagements de
l'État des collectivités donc
effectivement intercommunalités qui
portent l'aide à la pierre et autres les
communes pas de souci les communes
peuvent être largement associés et
signataire et on demande aux
intercommunalités aussi de prendre
langue avec les communes les bailleurs
sociaux Action Logement et la Caisse des
Dépôts si besoin et donc l'idée c'est de
se dire plutôt que de partir d' grand
objectif national ce qu'avait fait par
exemple Emmanuel Varon un moment donné
il faut 120000 logements sociaux à
l'échelle nationale moi je préfère
décliner ça sur les territoire et de
dire voilà dans le territoire de la
métropole dijonaise il faut tant de
production de logement et on s'engage
nous interbailleur et on s'engage voilà
donc c'est le renvoi à l'échelle des
territoires des objectifs concernant le
logement locatif social et enfin j'ai
répondu un peu sur le statut fiscal des
bailleurs privés mais je vais
compléter je partage avec vous l'idée
que il faut garder des investisseurs
locatifs particuliers je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous les particuliers
doivent rester intéressés à
l'investissement
locatif comme je le disais tout à
l'heure je suis pas certain aujourd'hui
que le pinal correspond totalement à
l'outil dont on a besoin demain pour les
raisons que j'évoqué tout à l'heure et
j'ai montré ses limites aujourd'hui et
ce qu'il a aussi
provoquer je pense que l'autre l'autre
question qui est posée à la mission
parlementaire sur la fiscalité locative
c'est celle-là c'està-dire comment on
réussit quand même à intéresser nos
concitoyens à investir dans le locatif
privé je suis d'accord avec vous on a
besoin on a besoin de particuliers qui
investissent dans le locatif privé on en
a besoin on en a besoin je suis d'accord
la question c'est comment effectivement
on leur permet aujourd'hui d'investir
alors que les rendements locatifs
restent faibles donc aujourd'hui la
question de la fiscalité est posée donc
je parle pas trop de statut du bailleur
parce que c'est une question dont on a
déjà beaucoup débattu et beaucoup sur
laquelle on a beaucoup discouru mais au
moins la question de la fiscalité
locative si on peut se mettre d'accord
sur une fiscalité qui soit à la fois
incitative et juste et ben c'est le le
rôle de cette mission parlementaire euh
il y a la question du logement des
saisonniers qui renvoie plus largement à
la question du logement en général et
aussi l'rition par les meublés
touristique qui ont fait beaucoup de mal
hein on on a parlé j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure de la préparation d'un plan sur
le logement étudiant vous savez sur le
logement étudiantou sur le logement des
saisonniers les meublés touristiques ont
fait beaucoup beaucoup de mal et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il est urgent qu'on
arrive à réguler ça et après qu'on
arrive à produire du logement pour les
saisonniers on travaille avec Action
Logement notamment sur cette question et
et qu'on arrive également à à à trouver
des réponses pour les étudiants et je
crois beaucoup moi au fonciers
disponibles sur les campus
universitaires je crois beaucoup aux
transformations de bureaux en résidence
étudiante je crois beaucoup aussi à la
colocation étudiante chez les bailleurs
sociaux il y a des territoires qui ont
encore des grands log et qui nont pu
forcément des grandes familles pouvoir y
développer de la colocation à
destination des étudiants permettre nos
étudiants ont beaucoup souffert
récemment notamment de la trition des
logements liés au meublet touristique je
pense qu' il va falloir essayer
d'accompagner ça voilà monsieur le
Président je sais pas si j'ai pu
répondre à toutes les questions j'en
suis pas certain mais en tout cas si je
l'avais pas fait mon cabinet se tient à
votre disposition Arnaud cursante mon
directeur de cabinet Stéphane Créel qui
est conseiller la Emmanuel barrier qui
est conseillère parlementaire on reste
bien à votre disposition et si vous
souhaitez me rencontrer également on est
à votre disposition merci à vous merci
monsieur le ministre vous aurez noté
dans cette audition tout l'intérêt de
nos collègues sur ces questions donc je
crois qu'on a bien fait avec le
rapporteur général de vous inviter et
merci d'avoir répondu je crois assez
largement et assez complètement à
l'ensemble de nos questions merci encore
et bonne fin de journée monsieur le
ministre merci
l'assemblée